yeah I'm curious you didn't when you
auditioned for this part in in the movie
you didn't know what you're auditioning
for you didn't even know what movie
you're on oh go but you know these these
big superhero movies they usually go
into code names sometimes with like with
all right scripts and things like that
dummy size or things like that so this
was called a a hab or something like
that but I do it anyway I do it you know
my agent told me that it's a good it's a
good uh you know be dead right well I
found out what this the thing I found
out later on that it was Aquaman when
James apparently was interested in me
for the role and he wanted to meet me
and so I said oh so it's the mr. Aquaman
movie so my agent says yeah I said hey
since I'm about to fly down to Los
Angeles to meet James that might be a
good time to tell you that um and I
don't want to be this you know the guy
to say this but I can't swim so she says
[Applause]
[Laughter]
don't clap for that don't clap for that
we don't what to club so so my agent
says do not tell them whatever you do do
not tell them that I said look I'm
already 10 steps if he asks I say almost
I'm a shark so eventually we get down to
Australia and this the first day that I
get there the first thing I do I go to
the sporting goods store and I get up I
get some like Olympic goggles in a
kickboard and I'm taking it very
seriously and I'm downstairs secretly
learning how to swim
almost everybody had floaties no I was
supposed to have floaties it was there
was I mean it was only four feet you
know and there was no time for floaties
it was like look I'm shooting in two
weeks I got my goggles I got my keyboard
let's get to work so eventually you know
long story short I teach myself over the
course of a couple of weeks that get
better and better I teach myself out of
swim and then we get to the set lo and
behold I don't have to swim in the movie
I got a skillful road
you